pull up uh what Davos is meeting here
and what they said is the crisis they're
most worried about two years versus 10
years okay so these are the things they
put out just recently what things to be
worried about two years versus 10 years
in the two-year side World economic
Forum uh you will see at number 10
pollution then economic downturn then
involuntary migration in voluntary
migration then inflation lack of
Economic Opportunity
Interstate armed conflict Rob can you
zoom in a little bit cyber security
number four and then you have uh uh
social uh polarization societal
polarization extreme weather events and
number one is what misinformation and
disinformation of course because of
election yeah look at the 10 year number
go to 10 years number 10 is pollution
then it's uh look how many of them are
green by the way everything's about
climate change right so no how of them
are green so pollution societal
polarization cyber security and
voluntary migration adverse outcomes of
AI technology misinformation
disinformation so we're going to stop
lying lying is going to decrease in the
next 10 years from mainstream media is
what they're saying so natural resource
shortage and then what is that one blood
diversity
biodiversity is code for overpopulation
using up the Earth wow natural resource
shortage and biodiversity loss and
ecosystem collapse critical change to
Earth Systems and number one extreme
weather events Tom you see this what do
you think about I I think over 10 years
they're worried about population and
number five and six is maybe they're
worried about their control of messaging
and then involuntary migration I don't
think they really care and then societal
polarization I don't think they really
care they're using that as a tool right
now to everybody against each other but
then number 10 pollution is directly
related to number three so three of
these on here actually four of them are
related to we as the people there's too
many of us and we're crushing the Earth
that we've been given and we don't have
the ability to control the messaging
properly and then this migration thing
is going to be a problem too and by the
way involuntary migration you know why
that's a problem Pat because you have
too many poor people over here that are
trying to get over there so it's also
overpopulation the one of their core
tenance and I've said this like 10 times
last 5 minutes is they want to solve
overpopulation and the way they solve
that is not good yeah oh you you know
how else you could help in depopulating
people have diversity for Pilots for
United but by the way look at two years
number one oh you want to kill people
have Pilots be that that's 200 people a
pop look at two years right now number
one Global threat to them is
misinformation and disinformation but
notice how they're going to bust their
asses because it's Elon Musk at the end
of the day I don't I don't think people
realize and I've said this before how
much credit you have to take your hat
off to Elon Musk because he's giving us
the you know why he's such a threat guys
why Elam mus is such a threat to the
establishment because we get to see and
hear everything that's negative about
the government and big Pharma fizer and
Mna and all these idiots anyway um
number one is misinformation
disinformation Tom in their tenear plan
they're going to get rid of people like
him they're going to try to discredit
him they're going to try to get rid of
his business and that's why on 10 years
he drops down people like that drop down
the five so right now it's control the
information push all that uh
climate change climate stuff which is
going to take over the next 10 years
that's what I see when I see that chart
well I actually agree with why number
one this year would be misinformation
and disinformation because of all the
elections that are taking place in 2024
we just saw Taiwan so whether it's
misinformation or disinformation or CIS
information and you identify as a
straight white information guy the the
information we're going to see deep
fakes we're going to see AI generated
stuff we're going to see all that
especially in the election cycle here in
the United States especially with Russia
tampering elections especially with Iran
and you know all their friends out there
uh causing Terror we're going to see
misinformation and disinformation in
2024 no doubt but their long-term agenda
is certainly the um climate crisis and
overpopulation I like how 5 six and
seven are not a problem in 10 years yeah
weird arm conflict lack of economic
inflation no no we're going to fix all
that with a one world government and we
don't
any so if you like this clip and you
want to watch another one click right
here and if you want to watch the entire
podcast click right
here